what up reject nation we are gonna watch
today the jurassic world dominion
trailer number two before we hop into
that greg why are you wearing a spider
man shirt because today's video sponsor
is spider tanks it is and spider tanks
if you don't know is a brand new pvp
brawler from our friends at gala games
and award-winning developer game media
whether you're going up against a few
friends or taking on players around the
globe you're gonna have a blast with
this game choose your tank body add
weapons and play to earn upgrades that
you yourself own and are free to sell
trade and even collect rewards i want to
say collect rewards on thanks to the
games blockchain base web 3 construction
i thought i said it better the free beta
is live right now live so head on out
right down to our link in the
description and start building and
owning your own armory with spider
tanks think now would be a good time to
move on we should move on to the
[Music]
blue had a video that's impossible
hey girl
anything's possible this world
life uh finds a way
[Music]
we made a terrible mistake
finally you admit this wednesday clock
might be about out of time
man
bigger and better
oh ouch clotheslined
this is gonna be insane
i could use your expertise
goddamn right you can't of course you
could
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
everyone's doing to a dinosaur
yeah
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
wow this is gonna be beautiful man
i love the feathers right
no
biggest carnivore the world has ever
seen
[Music]
ah
like a good dino crisis
that was like just on par with the first
truth these trailers they feel like you
can just watch their own little short
films so good like we should cherish
these moments because you know no matter
how the movie is which i'm expecting
good things but these trailers have just
been so much fun to watch i'm rooting
for the dinosaurs i'm rooting for them
to take over how baller of a move would
that be if the dinosaurs are the ones
who ultimately take over earth who have
dominion oh my goodness that would just
be such a bold ending
yeah man it'd be like every horror movie
where the slasher wins and then it's
like a small band of misfit humans have
to band together in order to survive and
continue on the human race mad max
jurassic world and i would love if the
dinosaurs can learn to like communicate
with humans in some way that's even
clearer sign language with claws
so brilliant they're putting their
humans in so many situations you have so
much set up for so many different
occasions of danger and where they have
to survive things where any time i see
the setup in any of these little
snippets i go how the hell are they
going to survive that how could they
possibly survive that situation
but they're going to and it's going to
be freaking off yeah the more impossible
these get somehow the more like
legitimized they try to make them well
there's a couple of things here that i
think they are going to do in terms of
character development which is something
i didn't think i'd be saying for a while
with this franchise but i think they're
going to be doing it bringing back the
old crew you know alan grant ellie
malcolm you're bringing them back you
know like they have that conversation
with owen uh or at least the way the
trailer splices it together a baby
raptor again him having a deal with baby
raptors i love it absolutely love it the
baby t-rex and the lost world that jeff
goldblum had to deal with the raptor
eggs and jurassic park
i love it absolutely love it i adore it
they're all like you you made a promise
to a raptor about it showing
that they are not attuned at all to the
evolution of communication that could
possibly happen with really having a
bond with the dinosaurs like animals you
know what i mean so i think that is
going to be part of their learning
lesson because there's even one shot
there where you see that dr grant is
part of it where they are trying to like
calm a rapture i think it is the blues
daughter their daughter or son i forgot
i think it's daughter what does it
matter it's a blues local times it's
gotta be a daughter so it's uh blue's
child down so i think dr grant is really
gonna have to learn like oh even with
the carnivorous ones there's a way to
create a relationship with them i think
that's gonna be like a fun part of it
that could be cheesy or it could be cool
so it looks like an old dog can learn
new tricks from our little boy owen you
know what i mean that's right man owen
is gonna take that old fogey franchise
uh veteran he's gonna turn him into a
compassionate accepting raptor lover
it's gonna be great yes and then you
know with blue's child getting kid
poached at the beginning of this we
don't know why it's kind of like a
children of men scenarios that's where's
the left how can you
it's like how how is the raptor able to
have a child how did this happen it's
going to make it something that's more
personally involved now i raise those
stakes are they traversing the world to
find this this child yes that way
they're going everywhere that's why it's
a universal movie that speaks to
everyone is because it's all just about
trying to find your lost kid and to
rekindle that love and show them that
you care i i i'm sensing sarcasm i've
never sarcastically where i was actually
asking a very genuine question sure and
even dr henry wu who went like full
villain like just
full villain in the last two this is a
matter of perspective man even in this
trailer you're seeing he's got a sense
of remorse here oh yeah whoa how
we made it
too far yeah what are we gonna we're so
busy wondering if we could we didn't ask
if we should it's almost like auctioning
them off to a bunch of rich [ __ ] in
the last movie it was a bad idea i
finally considered that when you know
maybe rich people shouldn't have these
things to point at each other almost as
if this would be impossible to keep
under control
and it took them like breaking out and
taking over the entire world to get the
point of garage at least in this trailer
it's showing that claire and i think
that character's name is macy little
clone girl yeah i know and are living
together yeah they're a family they're a
real family as opposed to the way how
the other two were set up where owen and
claire are not together and then she has
to go talk to him and he's like get away
i'm doing something manly right now yeah
man i'm building my house and now he's
doing manly thing here as a family
lou get back to blue's family and by the
end they're all going to be one big
family and then they'll probably have
coronas with the original cat and then
what's gonna happen the old team you
know malcolm grant and ellie are gonna
be criticizing
the type of methods that owen has
and then james gunn's going to step in
and defend the hell out of him owen
grady is very compassionate towards all
dynamics whatever you've heard about
owen has it no
from someone else and you are just
shocked you were just believing lies
right owen's a great guy and he knows
that these two actions speak for
themselves all right owen is a lover of
all people and dinosaurs alike bottom
line is like they showed us uh stuff
with our characters which is just really
the cherry on top
to all the crazy dinosaur mayhem this
beautiful trailer i've never been
happier my entire life i just want to
train a t-rex now man yeah i just want
to do the forced push of dinosaurs
all right guys well thank you so much
for being here uh this was a true
pleasure let's do a
pandemic jones pandemic jones you know
what i want to see is a pandemic that
happens but it's a bunch of pjs that
have been cloned you that's your
initials i'm not talking about pajamas
i'm talking about you pj spread
everywhere and then we're gonna be like
oh man this has gone too far there's too
many pjs we thought this would be a
great idea because pj is such a nice guy
so if we spread out pj everywhere across
the globe we would probably have the
most beautiful pandemic of all where
everyone will be more kind considerate
compassionate but the thing is when
there's too much of anything it just
becomes annoying after a while it's not
gonna be the thing we hope for where
it's just it's gonna get to a point
we're all gonna be like shut up because
what's gonna go wrong here pjs you're
not gonna have a hive mind everyone
talks at the same time like when one
talks as you just hear it's just a loud
echo of just all pjs around the world
eventually it's just all dominating but
you know what you're gonna be dominant
pj you're gonna be the purest original
pj and you're the only one who doesn't
have to talk along with the hive mind
bottom line is this is going to be
terrible for us but great for you so
thanks for being here and being a super
sexy reject annoying our lives but
making our lives a better place
[Music]